for like on a general idea is somebody
who can pay their bills keep a roof over
their head feed themselves the basic the
basic Provisions
that's the basics sorry sorry the high
value man is what say that again so a
high value like for me yeah what puts
you in the first like bracket of being
high value is being able to provide
yourself before yourself fully so if you
can feed yourself clothe yourself
um home yourself you know have like
spare stuff going on that you can do
you've reached a point of high value
because there is a lot of people
let me finish let me finish listen let
me finish let me finish just like this
just like there's a whole Spectrum
there's also a high value Spectrum do
you understand so the bottom the bottom
end of high volume is being able to
provide because there is a lot of men in
this world that cannot do that yes now
what happens those are the ones that we
say they're trash now what happens is
women are looking at the top tier of the
high value which is which is the
basketball players the football players
and these guys and these guys hold on
let me finish and these guys are not the
men the husbands that you all claim you
want because they're the most ones that
are least monogamous they have the most
options and everybody's going for them
but the stuff that you're actually
asking for the dudes just below them and
slightly below actually a more
overqualified to actually provide that
but because you're so looking up in the
stars and gazed by the lights you're
actually missing the real dudes that
you're supposed to grow with as a
journey like these two have well I I say
the average and I got cheated on so it
made no difference it probably wasn't
average if he had the option to cheat he
was probably above average but but
there's like five pillars of high value
man it's not just like taking care of
your bills and they they talk about how
entertainers aren't in the high value
Man category automatically thank you
they're not they're not why do people
act like these
no it's like um basketball players
um they they're like have a 92 chance of
getting divorced within like five years
after leaving the league and um football
players it's like a 60 or seven and uh I
think it's higher than the I think it's
78 chance of getting divorced but Kevin
Samuels there's like five pillars of a
high value man yeah no I watch Kevin and
that's what I was saying like this is
Spectrum right and that's what I'm
saying like the basics the basic level
which most majority women who are also
on that same level they miss that would
you mean the same level though because
can I just finish my point when because
I started talking about the high value
men right about the fact that we're
talking about so let's say high volume
if I'm talking about a high value man
I'm talking about he's probably making
about
80 in in UK 80 plus K he's got his own
apartment I I personally would speak
like that right so essentially why would
this man work for 20 years or whatever
to establish himself and then he why
would he want to be with a girl that um
has slept with 20 30 guys don't get me
wrong I'm not saying that every single
guy that's over 30 wants a 21 year old
because some people do actually want
someone to grow old with and have a nice
conversation with it's not just about
sex and fertility but at the end of the
day there is they've got the Spectrum to
choose if we're just talking about guys
like yourself
the regular guys yeah 90 of these yeah
you know making all right money but
really and truly can they really ask for
a virgin but when they get of course
they can when they get there no they
have their own why when they get to make
it so because because she's not that
she's not a one percent Ain't nobody got
the right person no virgin what are you
doing
you're the same girl that'll say women
can ask for whatever they want but men
can't ask for when did I ever say that
they say that oh you insinuated often
often no oh my God
stop guys okay
okay I don't even remember what we're
talking about now moderation what I was
saying match your level as in yeah you
know you're right I think actually a lot
of times like The Virgins aren't who
guys would think like I think if you
like a lot of virgins I know are really
awkward I don't even think they would
like I'm learning things or that
attracted like I don't know and also if
somebody's a 80 130 Grand a year are
they they're going to be of a certain
age right so they're not gonna meet
somebody who's single that's in their
20s there's a virgin that's necessarily
at their level that they want to match
and grow with because nobody now you
want to meet a woman who's also doing
her thing and not just our home waiting
for their man to come and no I mean guys
like that they want a girl that's
waiting for them
at them because if the girls just sat at
home waiting for the man to come and
marry you they don't they don't really
care yeah yeah I mean blessing isn't
your girlfriend at home all the time
she's not nowhere else
in the garden yeah
I I don't think like the housewife stuff
is nice I haven't experienced too much
of that before but I definitely prefer
like someone who's also kind of doing
their own thing
yeah listen like why do we so women have
all these like standards for men like
you have to be this and that I don't I
don't think it's bad for me to be like
all right I would hope you're educated
and I hope you're also doing something
reasonably respectable right it's not
just me that has to work in the top
place you have to be equally yoked
that's me that's like creative like
because for me if I'm sat at home doing
nothing just waiting for my man to come
home like what I'm like what am I doing
like what am I doing like what am I
doing it's kind of weird doing something
else
cooking food waiting for it yeah no I
mean if it was me there's always making
another Bowl
I'm just thinking if if it was if you're
married to a high value man there's
gonna be [ __ ] to do around the
has he not got a cleaner
what do I look like a cleaner
wait wait wait
you're very mad why wouldn't you clean
no but why wouldn't we have a cleaner
like I have a cleaner like it's true
they always get Killers though I
personally haven't I've got two children
and I've got my own creative things that
I'm doing so I'm not cleaning toilet I
don't know sometimes I'm retired some
people value privacy so it's like when
you have all these random people in your
home you kind of lose an element of
privacy I mean yeah I mean you could
have a cleaner and we could have it
forever
there's always [ __ ] to do around the
house
I mean you can't I mean if you guys talk
to you I started messaging with like
real Homemakers oh my God they make all
their food from scratch like a lot of
times they Garden it themselves like a
lot of them yeah running a home is not
easy
a lot of times they watch the kids a lot
of times they'll homeschool them like
yeah I guess it depends
but a lot of the women I meet in London
that are like I always feel like if if
she stays home a lot then she's gonna do
all this hard work but eventually she's
gonna be like oh I need some help and we
need to hire a maid oh we need we need
like a nanny to help because that's what
they do and then she'll want to do other
things and then naturally when
infidelity comes into the picture or
your your wife has like six hours a day
like so I can more easily trust someone
who also has a career because the women
who are kind of you know cheating in
their marriages or women who have spare
time
like man that's how I think but I don't
know it's so crazy that is that people
you said when you describe the high
value man the first thing you went to
was Finance do you not know that a man's
Financial Peak the point out where he
makes the most money in his life is
51 and that's what I was saying so if
you're not 25 if you're not between 20
and if you're not between 18 and 30 and
we'll be happy dating a 51 year old get
this fairy tale out of your head hold on
hold on let me finish let me finish and
just to go on what you're about to say
get better at picking a dude who is
going to become as many of you know I
was just banned on Tic Tac and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible